-Good evening,
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We're so happy
to be with you this evening,
and now we're gonna
get to the news.
President Biden yesterday
held a 1 hour and 51 minute
press conference.
It was the first thing
Americans actually wish
Joe Manchin had stopped.
During his press conference
yesterday, President Biden said
Republicans were responsible
for some of his stalled agenda
and added, "I honest to God
don't know what they're for."
Of course, that's the same thing
he said about Airpods.
[ Laughter ]
Today is the one-year
anniversary
of President Biden's
inauguration,
and he's not gonna like
Amanda Gorman's new poem.
"There once was a man
named Joe Biden
whose office
he usually cried in."
All right, that's enough!
President Biden said yesterday
that his first year in office
has been "a year of challenges."
But he'd rather focus on the
positives, like your COVID test.
[ Laughter ]
I can make it,
because I've had it now!
The Supreme Court
voted 8-1 yesterday
in favor of releasing
former President Trump's
White House records.
The House committee
investigating the January attack
on the Capitol -- 8-1.
This may be the first
recorded instance
of Donald Trump
inspiring bipartisanship.
Former President Trump
said yesterday
that House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
should be banned
from trading stocks,
which brings us
to a segment called,
"Ah, Dammit,
I Agree With Trump."
♪♪
Man, there is nothing worse
than hearing a Trump opinion
and thinking,
"The man's got a point."
But dammit, I agree with Trump.
The only other time
this has happened
was when he said Ted Cruz
might be the Zodiac Killer.
Oh, wait, I forgot.
Also, that press conference
where he said
McDonald's breakfast
should be all day.
-This has been
"Dammit, I Agree With Trump."
-A British judge
recently ordered a neo-Nazi
convicted of terror charges
to read classic literature
as part of his sentence,
including Jane Austen's
"Pride and Prejudice."
Said the neo-Nazi, "Sweet!
My two favorite things!"
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump --
They say "sweet" a lot.
People don't know that
about neo-Nazis,
but they're like, "Sweet!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Former President Trump
is currently on a media tour
promoting his new photo book
"Our Journey Together,"
and he's already being sued
by iPhoto.
And finally, a wildlife YouTuber
on a trip to Thailand
recently discovered
a new species of tarantula
that lives inside
of bamboo plants.
Yikes, that is a terrifying
thought that that even exists --
a wildlife YouTuber, I mean.
[ Laughter ]
And that was
the monologue, everybody!